let's bring in jennifer griffin now
what's your reaction to what we just
heard from president biden
well i'm trying to sort through my
reaction but i think what the first
thing i would say
is that what continues to be amazing to
me is that every time the president
speaks he sets a deadline that then the
military has to scramble to adjust to
meet he doesn't seem to understand what
it takes to either
evacuate people the build up the time
needed the amount of people that he has
promised that he was going to get out he
makes statements like all u.s citizens
will be
will be evacuated from afghanistan
right now the u.s government doesn't
even know how many americans are in
afghanistan when i hear the president
talking about these so-called
over-the-horizon capabilities there are
no over the horizon capabilities those
are empty words we do not have any bases
in the region where you can place drones
where you have intelligence officers we
now know have no partners on the ground
in afghanistan other than the taliban
and how's that going to work in terms of
over the horizon capabilities the isis
threat is real
every day that u.s troops are on the
ground at the kabul airport they are a
target they are sitting ducks they know
that it is extraordinary that they've
gotten 21 000
people out in the last 24 hours up to 70
000 but the people they haven't gotten
out are the people they promised to get
out americans as well as those who were
translators who are cowering their in
their homes who we're getting videos
from of their family members being
killed as the taliban close in on them
and the callousness with which the
statements from the white house when the
president reads those statements and
starts with a domestic agenda and then
says oh by the way here's what's
happening in afghanistan today it is so
detached from reality but the reality is
the american troops who are on the
ground at the airport who are having to
turn back people at the airport who are
having to lift babies and women
over the the walls who are breaking
rules at times to get people in who are
in need because the rules being sent
from washington to who can come through
the airport and the the taliban blocking
and now we have to ask
mother mai to the taliban if we can get
american citizens through their
checkpoints it's so
appalling and it didn't have to be this
way this is
president biden took this decision to go
to zero he announced a date september
11th of all days as as a withdrawal date
the military pulls out they have to go
back in within 11 days then they're
expected to move a hundred thousand
people out of afghanistan in a matter of
a week it's only been a week since the
the taliban took over and already we
reported earlier today the military is
having to pack up because once again the
president has given an arbitrary
deadline august 31st why august 31st and
the taliban now have uh have
you know when they hear the president
talk about a deadline then of course
they're going to uh make him hold to
that it's so baffling and the people who
are suffering are the afghans who are
being left behind the women and the
children who the women and children who
won't be able to go to school and those
poor american troops who are doing the
best they can right now being given an
impossible task i i can't even imagine
the trauma that they will they are
experiencing right now and that they
will be suffering from when they get
home and then there are the veterans
back home who feel so awful who are
getting whatsapp messages and emails
from their translators who sacrificed
their lives for
more than a decade many of whom
thousands of whom we haven't gotten out
we did not keep our promise and it is a
national shame
well said jennifer and we have a
question from greg gutfeld so please
stick around
yeah i about all this like mass weapon
transfer i'm trying to figure out if
this stuff is actually accurate because
it's so unbelievable i mean was this was
this
was this on purpose was this accidental
was this part of a deal that we weren't
aware of that when we leave we were
going to leave all of this all of this
great equipment or is the equipment not
workable has it been disabled like
there's all these
i can't i guess it's because it's i
can't believe the story so greg i think
you have to separate it into two parts
first of all when the u.s military
pulled out and left bagram air base and
left a fully armed afghan national army
of so of you know up to 300 000 troops
they had to leave them with weapons they
had we had spent 85 billion dollars over
the years there were bound to be
stockpiles of weapons you couldn't take
all your weapons with you and then
expect the afghan national army to fight
the taliban they didn't expect the
afghan national army to fold so quickly
my understanding is that some of the
more advanced equipment some of the the
helicopters and the apaches and whatever
they pulled though that that was part of
the retrograde when they left bagram now
that's not to say that some wasn't left
behind because again the expectation was
that the afghan national army would
stand and would continue to fight off
the taliban even if it were just for a
few months so they were kind of caught
between what do you do otherwise if you
really knew the taliban were going to
take over in 11 days you would have
blown up all the weapons depots but the
problem is they wanted to give the
afghan national army a chance the real
problem was when president ghani fled
that that and that army fell apart
all right we have another question here
from dana hey jen i'm curious about what
you hear internally
if you can speak to it at the pentagon
um if there's frustration
about
being
given a mission that they are not being
given the resources in order to uh
complete um and what also you know and
when a president speaks uh it's it's to
all these different audiences the
american public our allies our
adversaries but also very specifically
in a situation like this to our troops
and i just wonder what you're hearing uh
in terms of reaction on that end
well it's interesting i didn't actually
hear president biden speaking to our
troops um there's always that catch
phrase at the end god bless our troops
but i didn't hear him addressing our
troops i didn't hear him addressing
veterans i didn't hear any sort of
empathy whatsoever
the military as you know they
salute smartly when they're given an
order they get as much done as they
possibly can as quickly as they can it's
it's i spoke to some former uh
senior leaders here at the pentagon who
have served in afghanistan and i i spoke
to one last night who had would have
been in this position and had would have
had to oversee this withdrawal if
he were still in command and i asked
what is it is there anything the
military is doing wrong from his point
of view that he would have done
differently have been and and you can
quibble about a few minor things there's
been the debate about whether you should
have pulled out a bagram first and wait
the way it was explained to me is we had
a choice and this goes back to the
debating of the plan when the military
was given the order basically to begin
planning to withdraw
back in april
and that was do you stay at bagram
you're going to need a big force
protection to do that is are you going
to be able to get all those civilians
and and sivs and americans up to bagram
there are no there's not as much
infrastructure around there or do you
hope that the the afghan government's
going to hold and you you you know that
within the next year or two you might
have to uh withdraw uh citizens from
kabul international airport they opted
for that
you know they're pros and cons to both
but i think
the frustr
i i think
i just i see they are working under a
very difficult almost impossible
timeline particularly knowing that there
is an isis threat uh now remember what
isn't explained all the time is that
isis hates the taliban as much and the
taliban hates isis as much as they hate
us so isis would love to embarrass the
taliban right now they would love to
fire on the airport so that the
americans had to pull out under fire
there are a lot of different factors
there it is an extremely dangerous
environment in which they are doing this
they knew that going into it but the
blithe manner in which the president
seems to have given the orders to
withdraw
it just
it it boggles the mind that that this
was all known and this was all brief to
the president i know there were heated
discussions in the situation room about
the humanitarian catastrophe that would
follow going to zero and in afghanistan
but once the president took that
decision the military
had to do the best they could to ensure
that there were no troop casualties and
now to get as many people out as they
can but unfortunately time is running
out jen please stay
with us i want to play some sound and
then go to you dagon from general keane
who is on our air earlier please roll it
the troops are there to accept risk
to get american citizens and afghan
partners out
they are fully aware of that mission
i think we have leaders here who are
absolutely risk averse
they fear a casualty they feel somebody
getting hurt seriously they're wringing
their hands over this it's up there's a
lack of spine i think being shown here
this is biden's calculation as i see it
he is afraid to go past that deadline
because anything goes after that point
you could have a live firefight at the
airport we have guys surrounded who
knows what could happen you could have
massive casualties civilian casualties
he'd have to then send in more men into
the airport and that's a total mess he
would rather
leave
when the taliban tells him to on the
31st
just so he doesn't have to risk
that situation happening but by doing
that he strands thousands of our people
beyond the wire
americans are afghan allies and our
friends
jennifer to that point the frustration
i've heard from so many
veterans uh special ops
uh talking to them even talking to
a man who was flew a helicopter into the
eye drank valet first cavalry air mobile
they screaming
about let us go in and do what we do
this is what we're trained for
we don't leave people behind that's the
frustration and
president biden doesn't get that
well the problem degen is after 20 years
of war there are so many people left
behind so what are you going to do willy
nilly send every veteran you know
1.2 million or 1.6 million who've who've
served since 9 11 back in to get their
translators you have to have some sort
of organized effort the pentagon tried
to organize that effort but there have
been
various roadblocks having to work with
the state department having to make sure
the biometrics were done and that you
knew who you were bringing out
there are constraints
i think back to the point that jack
general jack keane made it is clear that
this president and any president before
him does not want another mogadishu they
do not want to blackhawk down they do
not want american troops getting
surrounded by a crowd and getting
dragged through the streets of kabul
it is understandable that is a that is
it is the u.s military's goal to get out
without having any u.s casualties and to
not have to leave under fire with with
you know in
any further embarrassment than than what
we've seen so far
so
given those constraints there is a
reason that u.s troops for the most part
are staying behind the wire at the
airport and
heroically have gotten 70 000 people out
in a matter of weeks
but that being said the heartache uh
being felt by the veterans and those who
worked with translators who are sending
them these calls for help
it's more than any of us can bear
but you can also understand when you're
the president commander-in-chief you
don't want to just send your forces out
willy-nilly in the streets of kabul with
such a hostile force now in charge of
the government
uh jen
to that point it's a very good one
about the veterans and i talked to a guy
special forces former formerly special
forces there uh he's been working around
the clock doing the fundraising trying
to get the interpreters here um he said
that the pleadings that he is getting
from them he said it is almost breaking
me
um and i wanted to just play this sound
and have you react this is congressman
michael walt of florida uh he was
speaking earlier today um on the ha at
the house
steps
about this very issue and i think back
to what you said about the president not
addressing them and it seems very
disconnected but take a listen to what
he said
when future american soldiers have to go
back in to deal with the problem
and deal with the incompetence of this
administration how many are going to die
now
because they're going to have to fight
their way through our own equipment
our own damn equipment
so jen i just want to maybe get your
take on that because there are several
members of congress on both sides of the
aisle that served and the anger is
palpable you had jason crowe from denver
a democrat saying similar things
i mean there is bipartisan outrage
certainly from anybody who ever served
in afghanistan we've heard that you
heard the emotion from congressman waltz
this is not a partisan issue
and what is particularly egregious is
that this exact same thing happened in
2011 in iraq
vice president joe biden oversaw that
withdrawal and three years later the u.s
military had to go in to fight isis it
is very hard to imagine
how what's going to happen when the
taliban begin allowing uh bases to be
set up inside afghanistan i mean once
again these over the horizon
capabilities that requires some
intelligence that inquires requires
basing we don't have that in that region
that so that is a you know that is a
myth
and
it's just
we we haven't talked enough about
pakistan and how very dangerous nuclear
pakistan is next door and you now have
the taliban on the doorstep and with a
an allied partner in nuclear pakistan
the the amount of proliferation of and
and also let's talk about how terrorists
around the world are watching this and
how is this different from the 1989
withdrawal of the soviets that inspired
al qaeda that then led to 9 11. i just
don't understand why we don't
understand that of course everybody
would love to see not another american
soldier be sent or marine sent to
afghanistan
nobody wants to stay there a minute
longer however
there was a way to keep a lid on things
with a very small footprint we should
have changed the narrative long ago and
i felt the media for this this was not a
forever war this was not america's
longest war this was an intelligence
outpost a strategic asset that we needed
several thousand american troops to
guard in order to safeguard our homeland
jennifer thanks so much we really
appreciate all those words and i think
the country understands exactly what
you're saying hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else